um hey everyone thanks for coming as he
said my name is KITT I'm a creative
director at Capital One and this is the
story of learning how to use animation
first in prata typing and then in actual
production work so a long long time ago
I used to be a print designer than web
designer then UI UX blah blah blah blah
blah designer and what I'm doing now is
called UX choreography if that's even a
thing
basically I'm helping designers move
things on screen with grace and most
importantly purpose um and this talk is
kind of about that here's my story
I can't code unlike many of you and what
it means I can't make my designs come to
life I've actually spent endless hours
in conversations with clients and users
doing user tests and trying to explain
how that little button moves or
something like that you'll know how it
goes right
you put a PNG in front of the client and
say it's London page and then you flip
next and it's search results and the
client goes like whoa wait a second
where where is the search we're like
it's that little magnifying glass icon
in the corner and the client is like
look how do I type and you look so yeah
I needed a way to prototype interactions
it was back in the days when there were
no beautiful tools that Dayton told us
about principle and pixate and all that
so I decided to start animating a long
time ago I used to just make funny gifts
in image ready so that's where I started
and that's what I wanted to do and then
someone told me hey bro it's 2013 you
know it's all baked in Photoshop now I'd
like okay so I started animating UI
frame by frame
Photoshop and it was every bit as
horrible as you can imagine well granted
I discovered timeline mode pretty soon
but still it didn't help much so then I
figured ok it must be about the right
tools someone recommended me After
Effects I downloaded after facts I ran
it and I'm screaming in pain ever since
it is super confusing even if you know
exactly what you're doing so when in
YouTube and I started looking for some
tutorials and there were a lot of
tutorials and telling me how to make
little blue ball bounce around what does
that have to do with my UI so figured
it's not about tools must be about some
sort of best practices so when to
dribble and I added animation tag on
dribble to my RSS feed on average people
post 100 to 150 animated gifs a day and
I was watching them all so basically
over the course of the last couple of
years I watched around hundred thousand
gifts and I didn't get mad in the
process and you know what something
really cool happened after doing all of
that I started noticing some patterns in
all of those gifts I started
understanding what kind of problems
where designers trying to solve with
their animation and I started collecting
things and categorizing them in dribble
buckets
I must have changed them like a hundred
times renaming you know stuff moving
stuff around throwing away stuff that
didn't fit fit anymore and after all
this time it turned out there weren't
any best practices not yet UI animation
was and still is a pretty uncharted
territory lots and lots of opinions
about it lots of speakers lots of books
some people say animation must
be functional then some other people say
it's about authentic motion and then
there is a distinct group of people who
believes that animation should be
invisible and a whole lot of others just
don't believe things should move on
screen at all unless you're in a movie
theater so I think just like Skywalker
on Dagobah we kind of need to believe in
UI animation first you know after all
those dark decades of web and stuff like
that
and so let's talk about the fundamentals
of it kind of the principles of why and
when you would want to animate your UI
and how could that enhance user
experience and make it better
also I'm not going to show you all those
hundred thousand gifts I only got about
sixty in this deck but fair warning if
you got epilepsy or something like that
please leave the room immediately
I like sci-fi as you can probably tell
the problem with sci-fi movies is that
they all happen in this vast fictional
universe that I have no idea about there
is a lot of stuff going on and only two
hours of screen time to tell me what's
going on that is a big problem so how do
best sci-fi directors deal with this
problem first they focus on characters
instead of the galaxy far far away they
kind of weave the history and geography
and all of that of their fictional
universe into the main storyline
so that you know people wouldn't fall
behind second they are making their
worlds feel real by describing
everything according to laws of physics
by making it fall
you know distinct physical precision and
great attention to detail
and finally they make their movies
delightful and memorable by adding some
sort of secret sauce something great
that keeps it all together as designers
we also want to tell great interactive
stories on teeny-tiny screens and our
characters are UX flows and our
fictional universes just our UI and
guess what we don't have two hours we
have mere seconds before users are
confused and have lost attention I think
we can use all the same principles from
cinematography and motion design and
kind of define three pillars of
animation functional material and
delightful functional would be about
seamlessly telling your story and
introducing your UX characters to users
in a timely fashion material would be
about making our UI universe feel real
and after we tackle those two delightful
could help people love our products and
come back for more everything we do
should be done for a reason if you're
going to leave the room right now
please remember this one thing okay do
not make stuff for shits and giggles
find the reason for it
so let's start with the most important
one functional animation one of the
first UI animations I saw in my life was
this little cursor blinking in the
ms-dos command prompt it was friendly
it was inviting like go ahead type
something but it was also functional
if the blinking suddenly stopped that
meant that the system halted and
possibly caught fire no to myself no one
watches this show
so it took me 20 years to understand the
meaning of that little thing it was
crucial the animation was crucial to
suggest interaction as well as conveying
the system states state changes in UI
especially on the web often involve hard
cuts pretty much all the time just one
screen after another and that makes it
pretty difficult to fall at times in
cognitive science there's a word for it
it's called change blindness and when
you kind of put something in front of
people and then suddenly change it it is
pretty hard for people to understand
what happened at a glance so this is
kind of how it goes imagine there's a
han Solo and widow sitting across each
other in a space canteen and then
suddenly there's this little spinner and
cut next scene Guido is dead and Han is
holding the smoking gun blaster whatever
so what happened did Han just shoot
Guido in cold blood or did he do
something first to provoke it well
that's kind of how most of the websites
and apps still look like it's just you
know a bunch of separate screens and
pages with little to no transitions in
between so functional animation could
help us fill those comprehension gaps it
would allow people to follow our app or
websites story seamlessly without
falling behind the same way they follow
the movie our brains are hard-wired to
detect moving objects to detect motion
this is a reflex magicians use movement
to perform sleight of hand right so they
kind of put something in front of us and
kind of hide something in the back
similarly we can direct people's
attention to what's really important
help them focus on important parts of
our UI while quietly disposing things
they don't need anymore
a good animation can tell the story much
faster than any words or illustrations
the language of animation is universal
you don't need to translate it to French
or Russian or Japanese well-designed
animated transitions can probably
onboard users much faster than any of
those fancy onboarding flashcards that
seem to be so popular lately engineers
and developers tend to measure
experience by page load time and kind of
abstract number of taps the perceived
user experiences rather different
anything we put in front of users takes
time to process it's called cognitive
load and if we add if we create
animation we optimize it really well and
put it there the page might load just a
little longer but in reality it could
really help people understand what's
going on much faster for example shake
animation on incorrect data entry seems
to take more time than just instantly
displaying an error batch in reality
users might spend up to a couple of
seconds just looking around for that
teeny-tiny
message and while the animated uh-uh
is just instantly noticeable and kind of
intuitive for most people material
animation the next pillar is usually
misunderstood okay it's not about Google
not at all
a little bit maybe it is about making
our UI spatially consistent and
predictable by following the laws of
physics when UI animation takes into
account things like gravity perspective
inertia velocity blah blah blah it looks
authentic and it kind of helps people
memorize our UI because it's familiar
and predictable they
understand what's going on but when it
doesn't look realistic when it's just
crazy from you know things are moving
from all places kind of like most native
Apple apps to be honest with you if it
doesn't look realistic it could make our
apps or websites look cheesy and people
could even just trust our content
entirely we create those fictional
worlds universes within our UI there are
infinite ways to do that as designers
you all know that every UI universe has
a unique map our off canvas menus and
drawers and floats and buttons and
carousels don't use carousels all that
stuff can be infinitely confusing to
people exploring it for the first time
if we treat our UI as a physical object
we make things come from familiar places
and can I go into predictable directions
that could really help people find their
way around remember people are new to
the fictional worlds we create they're
always learning everything from scratch
they haven't seen it in sketch for weeks
or month what you do and so people need
to really understand where things come
from and where they can find them again
and this is really what material
animation principle is all about it also
means these day and age thinking about
input device and context designers love
animating this stuff right dribble is
full of that and it might look good on
desktop computers but on touch devices
most likely it will be covered by users
finger and therefore kind of useless
another problem of UI animation is bad
taste
a lot of people I think a lot of people
don't like UI animation because they saw
something really crappy back in the day
and they kind of assumed it's all gonna
be like that no doesn't have to be not
at all
our taste is subjective but it kind of
it's based on aesthetics and aesthetics
are grounded in the laws of material
world around us it's been like that for
you know ages and ages so I think there
is a simple trick if you use laws of
physics in your UI as a baseline chances
are you would create something pretty
tasteful you know to begin with and it
would not go over the top all right so
let's say our animation works it drives
the tension and does all that great
stuff people get our UI they can
navigate they try we test it they try it
and they just leave how can we make them
stay well I think this is where the
third pillar delight could come in
really handy my mom's first computer was
a Power Mac it was 25 years ago in
Ukraine back then everyone was using PCs
because Mac's were crazy expensive I
guess that didn't change much since then
so when I asked her why did she choose
such an obviously more expensive option
over a PC she said
that was rational but hey humans are
irrational we're all irrational we take
joy over reason we kind of you know
choose delightful over boring I believe
is no longer enough for digital products
for the stuff that would build to just
do stuff it is not enough you know
things we build need to bring fun and be
satisfying because this is our life now
we spend our entire lives immersed in
those digital products but make no
mistake um animation and all of our
products need to be functional and
material above all else they do need to
work right so again please do not use UI
animation for shits and giggles
alright find UX problem it should solve
first but after the problem solved
what's left is emotion we all want to
have fun we want to love our apps and
websites and we want to relate to them
and I think this is where animation can
truly shine and help make user
experience delightful and memorable I
used to have a physics professor over an
Ukrainian politic Institute and he hated
Star Wars it was like lasers don't make
sounds in vacuum or artists said
lightsabers cannot exist if even if they
would they would never clash like that
and I was like so what it's awesome okay
that's precisely what we love Star Wars
for cognitive science calls this
suspension of disbelief this is when we
make a function a fictional tale so
delightfully engaging that it basically
lets us suspend our rational judgment we
love each other we love our friends and
partners and family kind of despite
their flaws right and when we love
something we're willing to forgive a
couple of glitches
beta version here and there and would
always come back for more
bottom line pure rationality is boring
take boring movie directors they kind of
shoot their Michael Bay I'm thinking
Michael Bay right now they shoot their
movies kind of by-the-book meticulously
using all of those best practices from
Hollywood and they do that without
adding a little bit of themselves to
their work without giving a soul best
movie directors on the other hand they
have very distinct and recognizable
style and I think we can also enchant
our UI animation with the unique appeal
with a certain brand that people would
love and always remember all right so we
talked about high level pillars now
let's get into details every sci-fi
universe has what's called a cannon it's
a set of fundamental laws and principles
the world lives by in the world of
animation a cannon was created in 1981
when two Disney animators Ollie Johnston
and Frank Thomas defined 12 principles
of Disney animation in their book the
illusion of life highly recommended by
the way so these are Disney's 12
principles a lot of designers already
know about them maybe you do too
and a lot of designers tend to kind of
cherry pick some of these to use in
their work but I think the original 12
are so great we can use all of them in
UI and UX well you don't have to do all
at once but they're all helpful so I
kind of grouped them and followed the
same basic pillars right so blue for
material green for functional and orange
for delightful so let's see how they
work individually and
in relationship to each other solid
drawing is the first basic material
principle is it's just basically about
honoring the rules of 3d space kind of
the depth high volume perspective you
know all that stuff Disney animators
made that a rule because they wanted
their cartoons to look more real they
wanted people to relate to cartoons more
they wanted to make cartoons more kind
of familiar and believable and guess
what I think that's exactly what we do
with apps anyways and what they used to
call solid drawing nowadays I think we
just call material design animators and
developers nowadays use different
techniques depending on how complex is
the transition if you animate simple
stuff it is called pose to pose and if
you need something much more complex you
use what's called straight ahead
technique and when you implement your
animation in code say CSS or Xcode or
JavaScript actually now don't use
JavaScript or interface you have
different object parameters to mess with
so features just one parameter take you
know scale or position or how do i how
do I show opacity change so if you take
one parameter that would be pose to pose
but if you want to create something
really cool and complex and unique you
can orchestrate multiple transitions and
multiple many many different object
parameters and by doing so you kind of
employ the straight-ahead technique
squash and stretch is a great principle
that describes the rigidity of material
objects one thing that people were
really confused about when Google
introduced material design was like hey
what does it mean my UI is now made of
paper what does it mean well imagine
that right your UI can be made you can
imagine that your UI is made of any
material paper or metal or plastic or
strawberry jam for all I know but
whatever material you choose is gonna
define the way behaves the way it
responds to human interaction and the
way things move on the screen so your
choice of material can pretty much
define your entire motion brand within a
product the way the entire product is
going to be perceived do you want your
app to be kind of sharp and exact and
organized and robotic or do you want to
be fun and humane and kind of you know
organic and fluid I'm kind of saying
like this is a good thing and this is
the bad thing but no not really you
choose whatever applies to your product
I made this website for an oil software
company and my client really wanted the
website to look and feel more oily
seriously that's worse he used this is
like crap
okay so oil is black right so I made
everything into dark UI theme no it
wasn't enough and then I was like okay
so oil is this kind of viscous you know
liquid so I decided to add these viscous
liquid transitions kind of like these
jelly like round things and that was it
he instantly loved it and he took this
to like TV commercials and all of it so
the choice of the right material not
only helped me build you know UI in
transitions it helped define the entire
brand and so that's what squash and
stretch principle specifically is good
for similarly arcs can also help you
define the look and feel of your product
and in your motion brand mechanical
things like cars and trains they tend to
move along straight trajectory
organic things like plants and
animals--and awesome we tend to move
along arcs right and similarly it's kind
of subconscious how people perceive your
UI but if you make things move in your
UI I kind of following straight lines it
will also be very like you know I its
IBM's thing right
it's called machines in motion right hey
iBM is lately very famous for that
they've got a very distinct and very
robotic motion style but if you need
something more soft and humane you can
use arcs which is pretty hard by the way
especially on the web this is one of the
apps we built for Capital One branch
iPads and we really heavily used arcs
here for many reasons first of all we
wanted everything to look more or kind
of organic and humane and and more
memorable and kind of really make the
experience of using those branch iPads
be more delightful plus we had a pretty
as you can see arts are actually helpful
to zoom in and out which is really good
when you're building a multi-layer
material UI and the navigation model is
kind of hard okay so the second group of
principles is about functional
properties so I know I started with
functional before but when you actually
build it it's better to start with
material kind of get down your material
principles and your information
architecture first and then you get to
particular flows and you start using
functional staging is the first
principle and it is about kind of
emphasizing the central idea of your
animation making it very exclusive for
for users this is about directing one's
attention to exactly where you want it
to be say the important piece of content
or suggested next steps suggested
interaction stuff like that
most of the UI's we build historically
they don't have a strong
kind of conceptual anchor as a result
people might get lost but you don't have
to rebuild your entire UI and just put a
gigantic button in the middle and like
kill everything else you can use motion
to stage everything and kind of you know
draw people's attention to what's
important timing is the most important
principle of them all no matter what
you're building what you're animating
users perception and comprehension will
be always driven by the way you build
your animated sequence so a sweet spot
for one individual UI transition is 200
to 300 milliseconds that's a good number
to remember it's okay if you animate one
thing like that little you know
hamburger turn it into X but what if you
need something more complex you have a
lot of UI elements that need to be
orchestrated in a big kind of thing this
is where you need to build hierarchy and
you need to be very deliberate with what
you make your primary motion or set a
kind of secondary motion what you slow
in or ease in what you ease out and
stuff like that
imagine you're editing an action scene
in a movie say a duel between Luke
Skywalker and Darth Vader first of all
define what's the overall temple of the
scene is it fast and dynamic and kind of
you know blockbuster II or is it slow
and you know thoughtful and kind of
dramatic I guess the former right so
then you okay you decide okay it's gonna
be faster than others and you start
prioritizing the individual motions so
something important like chopping a hand
with a lightsaber should probably stay
on screen longer and less important
stuff like I don't know some light
blinking on the background should be
shorter and kind of
overlap your primary motion basically
composing UI animation just like movie
edits and requires a lot of finesse and
a lot of practice this guy probably
knows what I'm talking about
the key to timing is cubic Bezier
function also called velocity curve so
standard code libraries like CSS they
offer kind of very basic out-of-the-box
things like ease-in and ease-out you can
customize those and it gets really
really really cool when you start
customizing those you change parameters
and you really trying to find the right
rhythm for your animated sequence follow
through and overlapping are helping with
that they are about kind of
orchestrating multiple simultaneous
motions things around us don't move in
perfect kind of order or unison you know
how in keynote there's like a build
order it always fascinates me like you
know what if I need things to just you
know happen simultaneously you can kind
of do that but not the point so when you
were building UI animation developers
tend to build separate transitions kind
of separate from each other as the
designers as designers we need to tell
them what should kind of happen in
unison what should be primary what
should be secondary so it's very helpful
to give them to give your developers
this waterfall diagram kind of what you
see in After Effects for example if you
use that those little bricks it is super
helpful for developers to see that
follow-through is about making the parts
of some big animated object like a card
or UI panel follow the motion of their
parent right like when I move my hand
follows me overlapping make sure all of
that happens simultaneously so you can
see like the low panel scale
up right and all the elements scale with
it for developer stuff like that is
trivial they're like okay of course it's
a class and it like scales and
everything within scales with it but
it's not as trivial for designers and
Schurz hal not travel for it users right
so make sure you kind of point that out
follow through also helps us communicate
the hierarchy between UI elements and
kind of set priorities what's more
important what's less overlapping make
sure that all of that is seamless and
rhythmic overall this kind of big
principle fall through and overlapping
helps you make your UI animation into a
blockbuster but really if you need it to
be if there's a good compelling reason
for it secondary action principle
specifically is kind of similar to that
and it is the bread and butter of the
slate of hand right this is about
defining what should be put in front of
the user and what should be hidden I
always ask myself so what is that I want
people to notice right and this is where
I am this is where I need to be what do
I need to get out of the way to get
there right if I think of my UI is a
physical object right it's kind of like
I need to cross the room just filled
with junk right so I need to move this
crate over here I need to move this
panel up this panel down get this icon
out of the way and so on right so you
define the important the most important
stuff that's your movie star that's your
primary motion right and then you kind
of overlap that with your secondary
motions obviously the rule of thumb is
that your secondary motions should never
detract attention from your movie star
ease is the secret sauce to any
professional motion design it's that one
thing that helps people pay attention
and also helps you make it look real at
the same time easing along with the
timing and overlapping helps people
build this comprehension heart to your
animated sequence on the material side
Ethan kind of helps convey the basic
laws of inertia right things don't just
instantly accelerate and don't stop
abruptly in our universe and when you
follow those simple rules of physics
it makes your UI your entire experience
more relatable to people in a
conversation people tend to pay more
attention to things that are clearly
articulated and they tend to memorize
what's being said last so same rule
applies to UI animation if you have
something important that is coming into
the scene it is a good idea to ease out
that to kind of slow down make sure it's
very clearly articulated right and that
it comes last what you want people to
pay attention to and then if you don't
need something anymore
it's vice-versa make sure you get rid of
it at the top speed at the top velocity
so that people on contrary would not pay
attention to it because you don't need
them to oh and here's one last bit to
remember about ease there is actually
there is no such thing as ease at all
I'm only using that word because you've
probably seen CSS or other kind of code
functions for animation in reality ease
in for example is just one type of cubic
Bezier functions you know the one that
is kind of more sloping in the beginning
more steep towards the end but that is
the cubic Bezier function if you start
tweaking those numbers and there there
are a lot of really good tools online
kind of simulators to mess with that and
then later put in your code so if you
start messing with those numbers the
results would be really great and you
every time on by the way if you ever
seen the bounce or overshoot effect
something that goes like this right so
just try making some of those numbers
negative and see what happens
anticipation is another powerful
functional principle that can be used
both in the beginning towards the end of
your animation it is helpful to give
people a clue of what's about to happen
you can kind of set the scene in advance
to prepare user for something important
happening you can change the shape of
your objects you can change the
composition and the layout of your
screen one of the really easy ways to
create that anticipation is the other
kind of ease it's the ease in right so
you kind of slow down at the beginning
of important transition or important
sequence and people wouldn't genuinely
pay attention to it in anticipation of
something happening right it's kind of
like and action that kind of stuff the
other way to use anticipation or
feed-forward some authors call it that
is at the end of your animated
transition animation could provide
visual affordance on the next screen to
users and it feels just like
conversation like hey check this out
there's an Afghan man you over there so
yeah most of those principles vast
majority are about making things work
right that's important but after you
took care of that
now it's delight time so you can have
some fun exaggeration is my favorite
principal hole and it is also the most
dangerous one it can make your movement
really stand out feel dynamic and fun it
can draw tons of attention to something
and make sure people will notice it but
if you over exaggerate just like in real
life it can get a little cheesy over the
top
the classic definition of exaggeration
by Disney is staying true to reality but
presenting a wilder form so it's a
really good idea to start exaggerating
the feedback of your UI controls right
so the feedback to users interaction you
can make it respond in a really
delightful and memorable way and
whatever you exaggerate people would
naturally memorize and kind of have fun
at the same time but you don't have to
stop at just feedback you can exaggerate
anything you want in your app right your
apps do not have to look boring unless
you want them to be right have fun
just make sure things are still working
they're still functional
finally appeal is the last and most
arcane of all Disney principles Glen
Keane
one of the best and most famous Disney
animators defined appeal as the harmony
of all elements I think this is how we
can create that coveted motion brand so
let's think about all the apps and
websites we use every day are they
unique are there other apps that do just
the same stuff or maybe even better
maybe have more features so why do we
stick to just those particular ones why
do we love them I think great apps can
truly surprise and delight us they can
enable us to achieve much bigger goals
and it's not enough to just make a good
user experience those apps have
emotional appeal people love them people
relate to them and people you know tell
stories about those ABS oh my god I had
such a good time in snapchat
a Pew principle also means staying true
and consistent with the style and
emotion your app your product conveys
basically we are all movie directors
when we build animation and appeal is
our secret sauce it is our secret
ingredient to build that unique brand
unique style that would make people
remember our UI and come back for more
so yeah let's wrap it up these are three
pillars to take away functional material
delightful make sure it works most
importantly make sure it makes sense and
it's kind of spatially consistent and
just make sure it's [ __ ] awesome
thanks
[Applause]
questions yes
as early as possible just like we
discussed here previously animation
using modern tools is actually very low
effort right so you can prototype it
right off the bat
sometimes build an animation with
principle is actually faster than doing
you know napkin black and white sketches
right so as early as possible put it in
front of people you know sometimes you
would hate your entire product and we
just love that little animation please
keep the animation it literally happened
with us yes
I still use After Effects because you
know I'm a masochist I guess but I would
most sincerely recommend principle to
all of the you know fresh starters
principle is amazing it has a very low
kind of barrier of entry it is great for
iOS apps pixate is amazing for web stuff
framer has no rivals right and if you're
like really into animations start doing
After Effects someone else ok yes that
is the best question of them all and I
specifically did not touch on that too
much there is a whole book on that that
just came out by Val head great
animation expert and it's called I
forgot
it's from Rosenfeld media it's something
something of of animation and that book
is specifically on point with
translating the animation into code I'm
approaching more from a designer's
standpoint not from the design delivery
point yes
just animate responsibly okay yes the
common mistake is to earlier point is
spending too much time right so the key
to mastering animation product is
learning to get something out something
tangible and helpful quick right
do not spend weeks and weeks animating
something awesome right just to find out
lately that you know no one cares thanks
all right thanks
[Applause]